it was just Tim and I it was really kind
of like two kids in the you know
kindergarten class and the teacher
leaves and they're just like running
their own class and there's no adult
supervision and I I didn't understand
until later what a luxury that was high
GQ I'm Danny Elfman and I'm gonna talk
to you about some of my more well-known
television and film scores
[Music]
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
I wrote music before I saw a rough cut
of anything I had a little extra time
and I thought I'd get started I read
this script and I wrote a bunch of music
all got thrown away as soon as I saw it
I was like oh
this is not the movie I was imagining in
my head this is something else
completely and Michael Keaton brought
this energy and that's what I'm latching
on to that it's really intense but it
changes changes changes changes on a
dime because that's what he is so Tim
just let me go crazy and run a muck and
I was like great if you're a game I'll
just go nutty the whole time until you
tell me to stop until you do like you
tell me that I've gone too far and he's
almost never told me that I've gone too
far fortunately which is one of the
reasons I love working with him I didn't
realize in hindsight how lucky I was
that when we did these movies nobody was
paying attention to us they were small
enough budgets that we could do them and
nobody from the studio ever showed up
saying can you play us some music there
was no presentations it was just Tim and
I it was really kind of like two kids in
the you know kindergarten class and the
teacher leaves and they're just like
running their own class well I'm back I
feel real good about myself you know
what I mean so without further delay
[Music]
welcome to Windy River it was a really
deceptively hard score to play I didn't
realize it at the time just the
Simplicity of um
really strict time so half the brass is
actually going
off beats like that and there's a
tendency to want to let it swing
no no no no no and portugu player is
like turning blue
without a break just like
they tried to record it in England like
for a best of album the conductor in
England looked at the score and they
started playing he picked it up and he
threw it on the floor and he said this
is unplayable
and it's like I'm enjoying this I mean
weirdly this kind of like weird stuff
was really fun for me you know I came
from many years with Oingo Boingo and I
was a total brat and I was out to
aggravate everybody I don't know how
else to explain it it's like I thrived
on negative energy in in the same way
that you want to kill Godzilla you're
not going to kill him with radiation
because he was made from radiation so
you hitted him with an atomic anything
he just gets stronger and that was me
with negative energy you know both with
Oingo Boingo and as a film composer and
I think that served me well because then
when I became a film composer I thought
all right I'm not going to write scores
like a band I want to write scores like
the scores I grew up on I was a a film
music fan so it's it's basically taking
a fan and saying here you go do it I
knew what the score is of course Bernard
Herman but I also knew Jerry Goldsmith's
work and I knew Max Steiner and corn
gold you know the famous composers of
the 30s 40s and 50s you know I wanted to
turn to that but at the same time I
still had a little bit of that punk
attitude that I took from the band which
was my combativeness all the other
composers hated my guts and I loved that
that fueled me on because every score I
was writing you know for those first
10 years I was writing it was all about
check this out that was my
motivating force it's like you're gonna
be imitating this next year
and you're gonna hate me for it
in hindsight I wouldn't have it any
differently if if everybody loved my
first score and I was accepted it
probably would have hurt my career
foreign
at the end of Beetlejuice at the end of
Edward Scissorhands it's like God I
could just keep writing variations I'm
I'm loving doing this and it's so sad
that I have to stop so to get a chance
35 years later to like do it again
that's like the weirdest sequel ever I'm
really excited to like get back into
that
Batman and Batman Returns
[Music]
I've never done anything harder than
Batman because first off I had to prove
myself you know it's like okay he's the
quirky comedy guy and here I am doing
like this Batman movie understandably I
think they were like uh we need somebody
who knows how to do this kind of music
but nobody knew what kind of music it
was there really was no superhero music
there was just Superman and we said we
know we don't want it to be Superman and
John Williams and then there was an
element with the producer in the studio
of wanting it to be a pop score there
was definitely this moment of like Danny
we want you to collaborate with Prince
and co-write the score and I go I can't
do that people go you really said that I
I love Prince but not for that score I
already knew what the score was and I
knew that if I collaborated he'd be
writing tunes and I'd be orchestrating
his tunes and I would be essentially a
glorified arranger rather than a
composer you know because he was world
famous and I was still nothing I had to
walk away I was so depressed I felt like
I just blew up my own career and then a
month later I got the call saying Danny
um you're back on we gotta get moving
come on come on it's like
this gamble paid off but it was a
miserable period of time on the other
hand I already heard the music in my
head I knew what it was and I was
determined that that was going to be the
score the producer was so hard on me
John Peters and then there finally he's
in I think it's the third presentation
and I didn't know how to do
presentations I was playing this weird
music stuff that was all like inspired
crazy and then Tim says play the March
play the March play the March that's
what he called the titles I go oh yeah I
got this piece here and of course now I
know you you lead with your headline
obviously I didn't really know
understand that back then and I put this
piece of music on
and John starts conducting in his chair
and at a certain point he stands up and
he's going like this and I and Tim looks
at me and he's like
yeah we got it
Nightmare Before Christmas
[Music]
was the most depressing time of the year
for me it was a very lonely time for me
as a kid you know I didn't have other
Jewish friends all my friends were
celebrating Christmas and I was just
kind of staying home playing some game
in you know my room or annoying my
brother and I imagined them all together
holding hands around a Christmas tree
and singing carols and you know just
kind of warm family thing in my mind all
my friends are doing this and I'm just
like
so Tim comes to me with Nightmare Before
Christmas and you know first thing is
like oh God Christmas here we go Tim and
I had never done a musical so neither of
us knew how to start and there was no
script and we're just like how do we
begin he said well let's just start with
the songs Tim would come over every
three days and I'd say just tell me this
story like you're telling it to nephews
and nieces you know around a fire at
night and you say okay come in here and
he'd show me the drawings and he'd show
me with zero and Jack looked like and he
goes Jack is wandering into the forest
and he comes across these three doors
and these three trees and he gets sucked
down and when the door opens and this
all this stuff he has no idea what it is
what is it what is it and I'm just going
what's this what's this there's other
everywhere what's this there's white
things in the air what's this I can't
believe my eyes I must be dreaming wake
up Jack this isn't fair and now it
wasn't decided that I was gonna sing but
I was slowly becoming more and more
attached to the character because I
wasn't quite conscious of it at the
moment but You Know Jack Skellington is
like the the king of Halloween land but
he wants something else and at that
moment in time I had my own band I had
Oingo Boingo but I wanted out in my
heart you know when you're the
songwriter and lead singer in a band
it's like that's your mini universe
that's your that's my Halloween land I
felt this obligation to keep going you
know because the band depended on me but
my heart wasn't in it anymore and so I
put that into Jack Skellington my desire
to kind of free myself of this
responsibility that I felt chained to so
I I understood Jack emotionally on that
level even though the creation is a
hundred percent Tim I was pouring my own
feeling into the character but who here
would ever understand that the pumpkin
[Music]
were tired of his crown if they only
understood he'd give it all up if he
only could
and so we went into the studio one night
and all night long I just recorded every
single song all the voices for every
song except for Sally's Song finally
exhausted it's like middle of the night
and got all 10 songs recorded I say to
Tim so uh Tim I um I uh and he goes
you'll sing don't worry
thank you because I was already
imagining a scenario in my mind where
well of course we're gonna have to hire
like you know a real singer professional
singer and then all these accidents
would happen like the singer would be
walking down the street and a piano
falls on his head it's like oh well
let's find somebody else so I didn't
have to resort to dropping pianos out of
Windows on on other singers
Edward Scissorhands
but Eddie
from all humiliation and discomfort
Tim doesn't talk about his films when
we're starting them I mean he's no
different now than he was 38 years ago
he basically will just show me what
there is to show he'll tell me a little
bit how he feels emotionally about the
movie he'll show me drawings and you
know in that case there was a script and
I read the script I didn't really quite
understand but you know from his
drawings I got a sense of it there was
no template for what this is supposed to
sound like that's heaven for a composer
there's no genre that this fits into so
I just started writing and for a while I
was kind of stressed I remember sitting
with Tim because I have two themes for
Edward really I've got this a theme and
a b theme and I think you know you're
supposed to just pick one theme for a
character and I don't have any Love
Theme at all and Tim is just like I
don't know it just works because one of
them became like the storybook theme and
the other became like the ice Dance
theme that followed Edward and I just
took those themes and I let them follow
everything from his perspective
[Music]
and like often with Tim's movies it
previewed terribly you know they'll
often preview a movie before it's
totally finished and the score is still
like a weeks or a month away from
recording and I remember being there for
it
the audience did have they had no clue
what to make of this thing there was
this one guy I forget what Anthony
Hall's character's name was he's the
antagonist in the film and this guy gets
up in the focus group and he goes I felt
sorry for him and I remember thinking oh
my God and Tim is like oh
this is not going well it really just
made me think more the sense that no
one's gonna see this movie and I really
love it but it's just that's going to be
one of those films people don't get it
and they're not gonna see but that's the
way I felt about Beetlejuice in fact the
studio tried to rename the movie house
ghost when it came out because they said
no one will come and see a movie called
Beetlejuice too complicated sorry house
ghost in the end they just said ah it's
going to be a disaster anyhow let's just
put it out and of course you know it did
really well and Edward Scissorhands
found an audience and uh it just felt
really good because I I just had this
sad sense when I was working on it that
it's going to be one of those a really
sweet little movie that 10 people will
see
Wednesday
[Music]
well I never done an episodic TV I'd
only written themes for episodic TV The
Simpsons Desperate Housewives you know
tales of the crypt you know it was only
like one piece of music and here it's
like oh wait I got four episodes so we
spent Forever on the first episode
because for Tim it was just like doing a
movie and he's like giving me notes and
talking about stuff and I'm changing the
red ants at Tim you know once we get
past this you know we're gonna have 10
days per episode to like do the next
three scores he's like really so once we
got it all defined with the first
episode then I had to dive in like the
next three were like oh my God I end up
with such respect for episodic composers
you know and fortunately I had a partner
that I brought in that co-composed the
score you know I did the first four and
he did the next four we got him Chris
bacon and he'd done a lot of Television
before so he was he would keep me calm
good don't worry Danny it's gonna be
fine Chris this is insane this is insane
any cup it's gonna be okay it's gonna be
okay but I you know it was so fun how
could I not love it even though it was
really intense
[Music]
foreign
's family and I really loved Jenny you
know it just helped so much when you
have a character on screen that you're
following constantly and you just love
looking at them her deadpan sensibility
which I really related to and of course
how could I not relate to Wednesday Adam
and thing you know I'm obsessed with
hands you know I've got amputated hands
I've got hands all over the place I must
have like 40 hands in my collection and
so you know here's like oh my God it's
Jenny Ortega and a hand it's thing that
I grew up with thing really when Tim
told me he was going to work on it
I really just said what took you so long
no like oh my god really you doing
Adam's family this is like supposed to
happen
so what was the conversation about
bringing in the original theme song well
you know Tim is usually adamant that we
not do that Batman we never touch it
Planet of the Apes we never touch it
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory never
referenced it he says I want to start
from scratch but with Wednesday he was
more open-minded and I kept saying I'd
like to bring in just a harpsichord in
the sound just to connect us to the
original and he was like okay we can do
that and the beauty of the original
theme which I love so much is that I
could be playing playing playing like
this whole piece of music and end with
it's the easiest theme in the world to
create a connection to and every now and
then I would sneak it in go see if Tim's
gonna like smack me down you know
I need listening again
okay I was like yes